Y fueron estas mismas mujeres,
cuando decidí llevar mi hiyab,
las que me apoyaron.
Y cuando sufrí acoso por ser musulmana,
siempre me pareció que tenía un ejército de tías norteafricanas
que me apoyaban.
Así que cada mañana, cuando tenía 15 años,
me levantaba, me ponía delante de un espejo
y me cubría la cabeza con una seda preciosa y brillante,
igual que lo hace mi madre y que lo hacía mi abuela.
Y un día, en el verano de 2009,
iba por las calles de Nueva York
para hacer de voluntaria en una organización contra la violencia doméstica
que había creado una mujer de mi barrio.
Y recuerdo que en ese momento sentí un tirón en la parte trasera de mi cabeza.
Luego alguien tiró y me agarró,
intentando quitarme el hiyab de la cabeza.
Me di la vuelta y vi a un hombre alto y ancho de espaldas,
sus ojos llenos de odio puro.
Luché y peleé
y al final pude escapar,
me escondí en el baño de la organización y lloré sin parar.
No paraba de pensar,
"¿Por qué me odia?
Ni siquiera me conoce".
Los crímenes de odio contra los musulmanes en EE. UU.
aumentaron un 1600 % después del 11-S,
y una de cada cuatro mujeres en EE. UU.
sufrirá algún tipo de violencia de género.
Y puede que no lo parezca,
pero la islamofobia y la violencia contra musulmanes
es un tipo de violencia de género,
dada la visibilidad de las mujeres musulmanas con los hiyabs.
Así que no estaba sola
y eso me aterraba.
Me hizo querer hacer algo.
Me hizo querer salir ahí fuera y asegurarme de que nadie a quien amara,
que ninguna mujer tuviera que sentirse así de insegura en su propia piel.
Así que empecé a pensar en cómo las mujeres de mi propio barrio
fueron capaces de construir una comunidad para ellas,
y cómo pudieron utilizar los pocos recursos que tenían
para de verdad ofrecer algo.
Y comencé a pensar qué podría ofrecer yo
para construir seguridad y poder para las mujeres.
Y a lo largo de este viaje
aprendí algunas cosas,
y eso es lo que quiero compartir hoy con Uds., algunas de esas lecciones.
Lección número uno:
comiencen con lo que conocen.
En ese momento, yo llevaba haciendo karate Shotokan.
desde que tenía memoria,
así que era cinturón negro.
Sí. Así que pensé... sorpresa.
(Risas)
Pensé que quizás debería ir a mi barrio
a enseñar defensa propia a las chicas jóvenes.
Y de hecho fui y llamé a las puertas,
hablé con los líderes de la comunidad, con padres, con mujeres jóvenes
y al final pude conseguir gratis un sótano del centro comunitario
y convencer a suficientes mujeres para que vinieran a mi clase.
Y la verdad es que funcionó,
porque cuando propuse la idea
casi todas las respuestas fueron en plan,
"Vale, qué linda,
esta chica de 1,55 m. con hiyab sabe karate.
Qué simpática".
En realidad, me convertí en la versión neoyorkina de Queens del Sr. Miyagi
con solo 16 años,
y empecé a enseñar en el sótano del centro comunitario a 13 chicas jóvenes
defensa propia.
Y con cada movimiento de defensa propia,
durante ocho sesiones a lo largo de ese verano,
empezamos a entender el poder de nuestros cuerpos
y a compartir nuestras experiencias
sobre nuestras identidades.
A veces tuvimos conclusiones sorprendentes
y otras veces hubo lágrimas,
pero sobre todo hubo risas.
Ese verano acabé con una hermandad increíble
y empecé a sentirme mucho más segura en mi propia piel.
Y fue por esas mujeres a las que no parábamos de enseñar.
Nunca pensé que seguiría, pero seguimos enseñando.
Y hoy, nueve años, 17 ciudades,
12 países, 760 cursos
y miles de mujeres y niñas después,
todavía sigo enseñando.
Y lo que comenzó como un curso de defensa personal
en el sótano de un centro comunitario
ahora es el origen de una organización internacional
centrada en construir seguridad y poder para las mujeres de todo el mundo:
Malikah.
(Aplausos)
Y ahora la lección número dos:
comiencen con quienes ya conocen.
A menudo puede ser muy emocionante,
sobre todo, si son expertos en algo
y quieren causar impacto,
entrar de golpe en una comunidad pensando que tienen una receta mágica.
Pero muy pronto aprendí
que, como dijo el apreciado filósofo Kendrick Lamar,
es muy importante ser humilde y sentarse.
Así que básicamente, con 15 años,
la única comunidad con la tenía algún asunto
eran las chicas de 14 años de mi barrio,
y eso se debía a que éramos amigas.
Aparte de eso, no sabía qué significaba ser la hija
de inmigrantes bengalíes en Brooklyn
o ser senegalesa en el Bronx.
Pero sí que conocía a chicas jóvenes conectadas a esas comunidades,
y era bastante reseñable cómo ya tenían
esas capas de confianza, conciencia y relación con sus comunidades.
Al igual que mi madre y que las mujeres de su barrio,
tenían unas redes sociales muy fuertes
que giraban en torno a proveer capacidad
y creer en la definición de seguridad de otras mujeres.
A pesar de que yo era monitora de defensa personal,
no podía llegar a una comunidad
y definir la seguridad de cualquier mujer
que no era parte de mi comunidad.
Y se debía a que, a medida que nuestra red aumentaba
aprendí que la defensa personal no es solo física.
En realidad, es un trabajo muy emocional.
Me refiero a que teníamos una clase de defensa personal de 60 minutos
y luego reservábamos 30 minutos para hablar y curarnos.
Y en esos 30 minutos,
las mujeres compartían lo que les había llevado a esa clase,
pero también compartían otras experiencias con la violencia.
Y, como ejemplo, una vez en una de esas clases,
una mujer comenzó a hablar sobre el hecho
de que llevaba 30 años en una relación de violencia doméstica,
y era la primera vez que era capaz de expresarlo
porque le habíamos facilitado un espacio seguro.
Es un trabajo poderoso,
pero solo sucede cuando creemos en la capacidad de las mujeres para definir
lo que significan para ellas la seguridad y el poder.
Vale, respecto a la lección número tres...
y esto fue lo más difícil para mí...
lo más importante en ese trabajo es empezar con alegría.
Cuando comencé en este trabajo estaba reaccionando a un ataque basado en el odio
así que me sentía insegura, ansiosa y agobiada.
Me daba mucho miedo.
Y tiene sentido, porque si dan un paso atrás,
y puedo imaginar que muchas mujeres en esta sala se sienten identificadas,
el sentimiento, un sentimiento de inseguridad abrumador,
a menudo está con nosotras constantemente.
Quiero decir, imaginen esto:
de camino a casa de noche, tarde, oyen pasos detrás de Uds.
Se preguntan si deberían andar más rápido o más despacio.
Tienen las llaves en la mano por si acaso las necesitan.
Dicen: "Escríbeme cuando llegues a casa. Quiero asegurarme de que llegas bien".
Y lo decimos de verdad.
Nos da miedo soltar nuestras bebidas.
Nos da miedo hablar demasiado o muy poco en una reunión.
E imaginen que son una mujer negra, trans, homosexual, "Latinx",
indocumentada, pobre e inmigrante,
y entonces podrán imaginar cómo de apabullante puede ser este trabajo,
sobre todo, en el contexto de seguridad personal.
Sin embargo, cuando di un paso para reflexionar
sobre qué me llevó de primeras a este trabajo,
me di cuenta de que en realidad era el amor que sentía
por las mujeres de mi comunidad.
Fue la manera en la que vi que se reunían,
su habilidad de construir para todas,
lo que me inspiró a seguir con este trabajo
día sí y día también.
Así que tanto si estaba en un campo de refugiados en Jordania
o en un centro comunitario en Dallas, Texas,
o en una oficina de Silicon Valley,
las mujeres se reunían de una manera mágica y preciosa
y construían juntas y se apoyaba unas a otras
de maneras que cambiaban nuestra cultura
para dar poder a las mujeres y otorgarles seguridad.
Y así es como sucede el cambio.
A través de esas relaciones pudimos construir juntas.
Por eso no enseñamos solo defensa propia,
sino que también organizamos bailes
y cenas comunitarias
y escribimos notitas de amor para todas
y cantamos canciones.
En realidad, todo gira entorno a la amistad
y está siendo muy, muy, divertido.
Lo último que quiero contarles
es que la moraleja de haber enseñado defensa personal todos estos años es que
no quiero que las mujeres, por geniales que sean los movimientos de defensa,
salgan y usen esas técnicas de defensa propia.
No quiero que ninguna mujer tenga que rebajar ninguna situación violenta.
Pero para que eso pase,
la violencia no debería suceder,
y para que la violencia no suceda,
los sistemas y las culturas
que para empezar permiten que ocurra esta violencia tienen que parar.
Y para que eso ocurra, todos tenemos que arrimar el hombro.
Yo les he dado mi receta secreta,
y ahora les toca a Uds.
Empiecen con lo que conocen, empiecen con quienes conocen
y empiecen con alegría. Pero empiecen.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)